for testing the movie in front of
audiences yeah who do that to you
somebody and says what was sort of the
reaction that you get from we tested the
audience once mm-hmm and that and the
score was through the roof sure we felt
like we didn't have to do it again it's
like taking your you know your your SAT
I mean if you score a 15.99 like maybe
you'll get a 1600 you know do you change
anything that noriso like no no no - no
no no of course we change I've changed a
lot
oh it's a lot sure but we knew that the
story for us the testing was is the
story working are the characters working
do they understand the relationships
between the characters is it get is this
fuzzy you know Rainbow Bridge that was a
huge thing I mean are we gonna keep
Rainbow Bridge or not and after that
testing we you know he's definitely
we're gonna what was the discussion
about Rainbow Bridge was well it's a
little out there got some people you
know and it's still you know so I think
I think it's gonna be interesting to see
when the movie comes out like okay what
is this you know but those who know what
it is it's very important to them so but
it was an astounding reaction was
overall yes we're keeping Rainbow Bridge
yeah when you're depicting something
metaphysical like what is the like were
there different versions of what you
know doggy have been potentially yeah
for sure I mean you know in my head it's
it was all with what the heaven part was
the his happy his happy place which was
established at the very beginning of the
movie and the Hayfield when he's doing
the shores with easin so I always knew
that you know I wanted a book and the
movie with that that you're gonna end up
where your weren't your most happiest
and with the person you're happiest with
were there other versions that were just
as potentially now mm-hmm for me it was
oh is that I mean you've worked
primarily in television so what was that
transition for you like going it was
very easy actually because with with
television the great thing about that is
that you're working your craft all the
time it's like you you're doing episode
after
after episode and you're able to work
with the actors and work with cameras
and work with story and so you're always
you know you're working it you're
working it with movies you know it takes
you know 15 months and more to make a
movie from pre-production to production
to post so you're not always on the set
you know you're only on the set for what
40 days short 42 days something like
that so so the TV aspect that background
really gave me the vocabulary and the
[Music]
you know the the professionalism I need
it and the security and the confidence I
needed to be able to walk onto a movie
so say hey this is how the same thing do
you have a preference between the two
all right
I love them both I love them both you
know I look for the effect I should love
TV because it gets into people's homes
and you can entertain a lot of people at
once and you can do a lot of different
things I love the movie thing obviously
the big screen is huge and that whole
process of being able to birth the birth
and this baby you know that's even birth
it all the way through is wonderful
how much are you looking to emulate sort
of the style the first film coming on to
it coming on to a see yeah there was
there was um you know I definitely
wanted to pay homage to his his you know
the farm look you know I think that's
really important for the audience that
has seen the first show and so that's
why we went back to the same farm that
they shot and everything else in between
was was different